das wusste dass die extra so ein richtig
großen
oft alter junge du kriegst das noch zu
weit zurück allerdings ein junger ich
muss das alles wieder aufbauen
du hast meinen experian kann es auch
selber aufbauen
ich habe gar keine xp von dir bekommen
hey ich hab 28h 20 treffen die ich alle
immer noch habe ich glaube das geht
nicht mehr viel noch nicht caps ep
bekommt ich habe auch nur ein level
gehabt also es war nichts aber auch das
habe ich nicht ich hab einmal gar nichts
bekommen
wenn ich sowas doch ich hab gleich immer
von keefe mitbekommen ich habe eine
kartoffel von einem zombie bekommt der
sänger als dieser epische radio das ist
geil kräfte das mehr an pflanzen
doch noch zurück schwere tier aber fast
nie gewesen und dachte jetzt kann es
machen ja ich bin ich auch ich war unten
dann will ich mich leider hab ich
gesehen dass der dena darum dass
wilander der macht bestimmt was mit dem
tier da dachte ich auch vom stärksten
ausdruck wer schon wieder aus dem haus
raus gewesen dann habe ich ein thema
ausgesucht ein paar minuten egal gewesen
jedenfalls ist die tatsache jetzt dass
du angefangen hast ich muss jetzt geht
alles wieder aufbauen und das heißt ich
unter sich und genug gerecht ich habe
mich noch nicht genug gerecht als er
wirklich so dass über ein paar level
verloren hat eigentlich muss gleich mal
mit meinen ganzen sachen die ich hab ja
gar keine erde dadurch eingenommen
reinigen lassen verloren und meine
ganzen items ihr dafür verbrauchen dass
sie wieder aufbauen
du kriegst schon noch zurück du hast es
wäre jetzt mal scheißegal wie ungerecht
das gibt mir meine eigenen stück ich hab
gar nichts von dir natürlich nein ich
hatte volles inventar das kann danach in
der aufnahme sehen du hast das heißt er
liegt noch alles oder was ja sager noch
dann sagt das sind alles man sonst
verlieren wir dass er richtig wie man
ein sind aber voll
ich habe ein paar sachen tun kann und
nicht mehr genug holz und mini kiste zu
machen scheint hoch gegangen um waren zu
lagern
nee nicht [ __ ] you do
ja wir so geht's nicht weiter falsch ein
erst angefangen jetzt kann er mit den
konsequenzen nicht leben blablabla ihr
seid wie so ein altes ehepaar er kann
sich jetzt doch ein kiste ich hatte vier
kids monatlichen eimer oder sucht oder
falsche fresse
ja ich habe alles was ich habe nicht mal
eine tür gerade einfach so hoch gegangen
kommt einfach reiner war luxus villen
ich nehme deine holzhacker mit dies fast
kaputt aber ich brauche ein paar kürbis
lauch mit henderson aber auch hier liegt
auch keine von allem immer nur die die
hälfte oder irgendwie so wahrt damit ich
noch machen was hat herr du hast mich
doch geschlossen oder bin ich von fall
schaden gestorben
doch leicht gelockt getötet
aber ganz wenig ich glaube vielleicht
noch mit damit wir uns mehr kartoffeln
machen können bei mir und mein schönes
match wurde ist weg
ich bin reiter springreiter hier musst
du irgendwann ursachen ab der zufällig
auch leben leben haben wir hat fox media
irgendwo gehabt vielleicht kann man ja
ja ja ja gerade vier skelette auf einmal
ohne witz ein wenig an springer das
knapp gerade ich hoffe ich komme noch
aus ein halbes jahr als nein leider nein
ich will noch nicht der walter bitte
stirb
aha das war ich nicht mal ein abtasten
durch münchen
warum wisse blümchen er ich würde ihnen
den links da tun aber nicht alle haben
schon sechs weil ich packte in dingsda
ein blumentopf eines wegen euch auch ich
habe ganz verstanden bugs die innen
blumen
banker blumen im blick habe jetzt
überhaupt schon neues thema ausgesucht
hat jetzt fast kartoffel gegessen aber
ich fand dass gerade auch ein sehr ja
genau du findest du eine kartoffel auf
einmal nein da es nicht auf gelesen und
dann habe ich doch hat er uns bewähren
hefti bis zum frieden teams gehabt bei
sicherheit für kinder ich mag mixas man
munkelt man weiß es nicht man munkelt zu
dem thema dna thema jener thema aquaro
rechtswidrigkeit ist eigentlich ein
server bei den spot echt eine menge
monster gerade sie wie sie versucht von
wolltest doch manchmal auf normale soll
noch mehr athlet ist dann zwar nicht
mehr die sind dann nur stärker dem thema
kommt und zwar einmal thema und zwar
kaputt thema von lully schlecker wurde
ein großer kessel kaputt mit ema das ist
meins das meint was so die weltkrieg
thema dma und lollis lag und zwar was
haltet ihr von mädchen ii spielen zocken
oder anderer spanien
ok ich denke damit ist gemeint ist das
nicht gut
totale gefährdung alter ist nicht gut
ich hab das machen wollen dann soll sie
es machen
in meiner spricht nichts gegen das
genauso wie das ich war ja damals ist
jetzt auch mal so gewesen dass mädchen
die fußball spielen immer so anders
angeguckt wurden so von wegen frauen
fußball wissen lässt dann quatsch ich
mein das finale von der frauen-em
er kostete eine karte glaube ich ein
positiver karte beim finale der männer
wm weil es eigentlich einfach mehr leute
anspricht aber nur weil das mehr männer
machen als frauen heißt es nicht leicht
dass es bei den frauen jetzt irgendwie
anders ist dass sie es nicht dürfen oder
so also ich hoffe ich trinke ich denke
da sind wir alle einer meinung das
machen wollen soll das machen aber bei
vielen männern wird das aber halt falsch
angeguckt so wird man da von der seite
so an gekürzte von wegen männer ebenso
viele werden sich auch freuen mit denen
zocken freunde gleich mir ist das
eigentlich relativ egal also wie schon
gesagt dass wer wäre gerne zockt er soll
tun was er möchte also man soll immer
das hobby ausüben aus einem am meisten
spaß macht aber an sich nur gegen habe
ich schon mal gar nichts wert wenn die
mädels machen und dann geht man mit
einem etat haben die man sich als bonus
weil war dass man das selten ist das mit
socken und dann ein cap europe' angels
oder so dann tötet man die dann nicht
also schon ab ich hab noch nie wirklich
somit zum mädchen zusammen gespielt und
sagen ich sterbe hier vorgelesen kette
auch keine wirklich sagen eine beim
neusser stufe die spielt wirklich immer
mw3 auf ihrer konsole aber mehr auch
nicht
naja nicht ganz normal ja ich kenne zwar
auf zwei mädels und die andere mp3 muss
sagen dass ein teilweise also war glaubt
man gar nicht mein mann ist das hat sich
ja sowieso komplett ob bei männer
verändert wo man sagt ja zur gesetzlich
ungefähr weiß ich was war da beide
mädels am anfang machte man das
aufzuarbeiten diese mädels den diesen
völlig normalen mädels ziehen sich
ziemlich gut aus er kann nicht sein so
gut aus also ich hab jetzt gleich
endlich wieder mein eingang fertig den
standort
wieso waren kripo vor meinem haus werde
das wollt ihr bei ich nicht das war echt
doof da hatte ich mit dir nicht keine
ahnung haben wir überhaupt leben
herrschen glaubt man alles geht davon
aus dass die frage von einem mädchen kam
das sorgt also finden das ok du darfst
weitermachen aber mehr als nur filme
okay das sind wir eigentlich gut weil es
mehr mädels geben soll die zocken sollen
können gehen soll nicht unbedingt mehr
geben aber es soll mehr also noch viel
zu wenige haxel nicht sagen das ist
durchaus mehr sein immer mehr gibt mir
mehr davon
eine männersache und auch immer mehr weg
ihr flieger überhaupt das headset stern
frucht cz gefragt hatte vorher gesagt
hatte wir sollten mal über irgendwelche
klischees reden
große worte gerade deutsche so nahmen
sie fest
ich habe dann gesagt wir brauchen ein
konkretes ziel und das haben wir
bekommen jetzt habe ich gar nicht
verstanden also ich wollte nur sagen
dass er solche klischees wie ja die
deutschen sind alle nazis und hier die
russen trinken wodka die engländer
trigema tee und tatsächlich so solche
klischees oder 10 welche anderen ja oder
das erhöht nicht zocken oder nicht
zocken sollten und darum was halten wir
von zocken den mädels
ich finde was willst du jetzt schon
wieder hier immer gar nichts wenn du ihr
etwas raus nimmt alter gucken also bei
mir auch immer gemacht
ich wollte nur ein bisschen kies am ende
das aber du hast bei mir mal geklaut
habe ich nachher in den base den
kommentaren wird höchstens mal essen
haha ist auch schon etwas wenn du eine
sache raus nimmt zu tun dass rein getan
hab ich echt noch auf die spitze
ohne witz jetzt kriegt der etsc nachdem
eine mine fertig ist sein super fleisch
ist auch wirklich ein grundstücks
gemeinschaftsgarten hier
gemeinschaftsgarten bis bilder zeigen
die mine gefahren
bei beiden tieren leben gefunden
endlich mit stop standen seite der map
oder so hier die ganze volk wo ihr euch
gestritten hat bin ich am laufen ob ihr
system gefunden
bis die ganze zeit gelaufen
du musst den flüssen bächen und flüssen
das richtig viel fluss im fluss und da
ist bei mir ich hab gar nicht mehr
inventar sie alles eigentlich machen
wollte wissen wie macht man denn
eigentlich muss ja auch zu brennen und
dann hat man drei stück sowie eimer oder
nicht das ist möglich lena gehen wir mal
wieder eine höhle gleich ja wenn ich mir
vier wasser gebaut hat wieder wenn du
kieskemper so aber wenn du ganz paar
mitbringen würde hieß es
also kannst du deinem keller was abbauen
nein du nicht den
habt ihr könnt habt ihr eisen oder könnt
ihr was für mich fahren oder darf ich
mich bei dir bedienen dena oder was wenn
du bei mir noch reisen findest kannst du
dir ein bisschen rausgehen aber das mit
bitte was übrig was heißt ein bisschen
90 prozent ja versucht das web wie deine
werkzeuge cdu nehmen alles health care
inc ist auch in meinem keller da unten
ist nur was der kanzler abbauen hier so
abbauen so dass hier
wenn du nach ávila und hinsetzt hast du
noch so ein geheim keller oma kann neuer
leider kann man nicht mehr mit fackeln
ab und seit 1 punkt
es gab damals sogar so ein kies kenne
radwegen trainer nur irgendetwas anderes
da und mach' ich machen konnte nachher
an das ist voll minute 45 also passiert
in folge
was hatten wir nicht schon alles für den
mädels und punktgenau fallen das ja
schon wieder gas welches akw sagen wenn
der cas schon davon wie gerade mal
direkt mit neuen namen an ein thema an
ja ich unser thema von jan leutner luca
und den ich will unbedingt mal eure
meinung nein mann ich will unbedingt mal
eure meinung zu diesen neumodischen wie
man sie öfters bei rtl sieht namen
wissen
bitte nehmt also das thema neumodischen
namen wie zum beispiel maja oder kevin
kevin ist doch nicht neu er ist nach
luca auch ein relativer karin war auch
mal ein neuer name so also was ist neuer
name als mutter schon namen sind ja dann
sowas wie william bell
bert oder sowas julia und damals war als
zum vor allem in den in der ddr populär
meine kunden die also nehmen also
amerikanischen namen weiße der kurzen
snack er da hin weil ich brauche das
irgendwie nicht gleich brauchst du das
aus dem italienischen wie bei felix weiß
ist gar nicht alles kommt ursprünglich
von glück also von fortuna aber ich weiß
auch nicht wo das nie wieder das außen
griechischen oder lateinischen kommen
trotz hunger kommt aus dem lateinischen
und heißt eigentlich dass das schicksal
oder ich weiß nicht wem fortuna
düsseldorf eigentlich glück freilich das
passt irgendwie freiheit ist deutet
nicht meinen namen um
es könnte aber im griechischen auch
ähnlichkeiten geheißen haben fiel und
lukasz neumodisch name ist es ist nicht
so direkt wieder gesagt wurde mal
irgendwie sowas aber hat auch irgendwie
ein